so welcome you all to the women of
getting Macmillan center for this
international in various studies at Yale
my key scroll compressor in political
science I am sitting in today Brittany
in Shapiro sterling professor of
political science and the Henry ruse
director of the Macmillan center again
not able to be coated a teaching your
class but I'm happy to fill in we're
both delighted to host Susan done this
year's real Stinson lecturer so as it
was the Massachusetts professor of
humanities at Williams College and the
author of a dozen books is including
Jefferson second revolution the
electoral legend crisis at 1800 dominion
of memories jefferson madison of the
decline of Virgin of Virginia
Roosevelt's courage how FDR fought to
change the Democratic Party which one
the henry adams prize and was a finalist
for Los Angeles Times Book Prize in
history it's also written 1940 FDR
Wilkie Lindbergh Hitler the election of
in the storm she's co-author with James
McGregor birds of rewrote the three
Roosevelt's patrician leaders who
transformed America and she's a frequent
contributor to the New York evil horns
professor Don is here to give us three
lectures under the title FDR's 1300 days
prepared for war in global leadership
November 1942 March 1941 the lectures
focus on three themes the first plan dog
from isolation to a strategy for war the
second a declaration of interdependence
lend-lease the third speed and speed now
mobilizing industry ate a loser for war
well here the first of these lectures
today the second tomorrow the final
lecture on Thursday and we hope you'll
come for all three the funding for this
lecture series comes from an anonymous
donor in honor of Henry L Stimson yell
college 1889 a statesman whose
government service culminated with his
tenure as Secretary of War during World
War two a fitting connection
for this particular lecture series in
1998 the Macmillan century since 1998
the Macmillan center and Yale University
Press have collaborated to bring
distinguished diplomats and foreign
policy experts to the center to lecture
on their books that are published by
Yale University Press previous Stimpson
lectures have included political order
changing societies by Samuel Huntington
financial crises in emerging markets by
Alexander landfill Lucy arms and
influenced by Thomas Schelling they
aren't Center the promise of moderation
by ambassador Marwood Marwan mature
beyond the democratic maze by John Donne
what happens to national liberation by
Michael Walzer and the imprint of
Congress by my colleague David Mayhew
I'm very pleased now to introduce
professor susan done so he will give her
lecture and then she would like to
entertain questions and comments in the
reception
well thank you so much for that kind
introduction professor skowronek it's
really quite a coincidence that you're
here with us today because I've been
thinkin an awful lot about your
brilliant book the politics presidents
make and I sure want to know what you
think about what happened exactly one
week ago and thank you all for coming on
this rainy dark day well it's a great
honor for me to participate in the Henry
Stimson lectures and world affairs
especially because Henry Stimson FDR
superb Secretary of War's one of my
heroes and I'm quite sure that Stimson
who was a courageous internationalist
and outstanding statesman would be a sad
and disappointed and shell shocked and
heartbroken as many of us are today that
our president-elect has declared himself
an opponent of the responsible political
and economic internationalist order that
has prevailed in the United States since
1945 America's leadership role in that
international order has served the
interest and prosperity not only of the
United States but of much of the rest of
the world and it has also served the
overriding need for peace and for
precluding a world war three well I'd
like to start my talk today with a study
in contrasts a tale of two cities and a
tale of two worlds in 1939 President
Franklin Roosevelt proposed a two-year
experiment he wanted to move the date of
Thanksgiving up one week from the
customary last Thursday in November the
point was to help businesses and the
economy by extending the lucrative
shopping season between Thanksgiving and
Christmas most states agreed to try the
experiment but the six New England
states and 11 others refused to go along
the mayor of Plymouth Massachusetts
where pilgrims celebrated the first
Thanksgiving in 1621 said that we here
in
consider the day sacred and so in
Plymouth Massachusetts on the fourth
thursday in november nineteen
forty-three thousand men women and
children many dressed in pilgrim
costumes crowded into Memorial Hall to
commemorate the first Thanksgiving in
the New World local citizens played the
parts of Governor William Bradford miles
Standish and the Indian King Massasoit
and reenacted three scenes from the past
the signing of the Mayflower Compact
that was the first written expression of
democratic self-government in America
the landing at Plymouth Rock and finally
the first Thanksgiving in the early
evening as they all streamed out of
Memorial Hall into the fresh falling
snow and wintry stillness of the
November dusk they heard the shouts of
news boys selling the late edition of
the Thursday paper Germany bombs
Plymouth 200 tons of bombs full on
Plymouth 48 hours the Nazi Luftwaffe
dumped its lethal cargo of bombs on the
British port city of Plymouth on the
English Channel a hundred and fifty
German planes battered the town and its
harbour destroying warehouses navy
supply depots freight yards railway
lines and especially blocking the
harbour so that new shipments of
armaments couldn't arrive the Nazi goal
was not only to reduce to rubble in
flames important military and industrial
targets but also to break Britain's
morale by depositing hell upon its
people exactly two weeks earlier the
Luftwaffe had indiscriminately dropped
even more explosives and incendiary
bombs upon the ancient midland city of
coventry destroying not only automobile
and airplane factories but also
residential and business areas hospitals
power lines and Coventry majestic
medieval cathedral a New York Herald
Tribune reporter wrote the
coventry has become and I quote the
voiceless symbol of the insane
unfathomable barbarity which has been
released on Western civilization after
that attack the Nazis threatened to
systematically coventry eyes the whole
British island when the minister of the
First Church in Plymouth Massachusetts
heard the news of the bombing in
Plymouth England he immediately sent a
telegram to his English brethren your
sorrows are our sorrows he wrote your
battles are our battles from Plymouth
Massachusetts to Plymouth England fight
on Godspeed here in the United States on
FDR's earlier thanksgiving day people
watched parades and attended church
services enjoyed turkey dinners played
football and when they all got home they
turned on the lights they laughed and
slept safely and peacefully in their
beds the president's decision to move
Thanksgiving up one week did indeed give
a big boost to consumer spending but for
the British people and for people around
the world November 1940 was a lousy
month and a test of their very survival
in the three talks that I'll give this
week I want to make the argument that
the several months beginning with
Roosevelt's reelection in early November
1940 and ending with his signing of the
lend-lease act in early March 1941
marked the start of the country's
intervention in World War two I call
this period FDR's third hundred days it
constituted one of the most productive
and crucial periods and his long
presidency and perhaps in the 20th
century too it was the administration's
covert declaration of war at his first
inauguration in March 1933 on a grim
overcast day in the dark depths of the
Great Depression FDA
I took the oath of office and then
addressed the vast crowd outside the
capital after making his unforgettable
statement that the only thing we have to
fear is fear itself he said this 8 this
nation calls for action and action now
that speech signaled the period that
historians call the first hundred days
during those first few months of his
administration FDR enacted important
economic and social policies that
restored solvency to banks and imposed
sweeping regulations on the financial
system extended relief to farmers
constructed power plants in the
Tennessee Valley and provided jobs to
millions of the unemployed through the
Public Works Administration historians
have named the summer of nineteen
thirty-five Roosevelt second hundred
days during this period FDR swung more
to the left and signed some of the most
transforming and enduring social
programs of the New Deal Social Security
the National Labor Relations Act that
guaranteed the right of workers to
organize and unions and engage in
collective bargaining a revenue act that
lower taxes on small businesses and
increased taxes on large inheritances
and the Works Progress Administration
that gave millions of meaningful jobs to
American workers and young people as
well as to artists musicians actors and
directors on November fifth nineteen
forty when the president was elected to
an unprecedented third term he wasn't
faced with an economic crisis or four
calls for more jobs and security this
time he was faced with a global military
political and moral crisis at stake was
not just the economic and social
well-being of Americans at stake was the
fate of free and democratic governments
everywhere in the world and the lives of
hundreds of millions of people
judeo-christian morality along with the
Enlightenment principles of freedom
under Laura individual rights and due
process all trembled on the bring
of annihilation in Asia Japan had
wrapped its tentacles deeper into China
in Europe all the democracies except
Great Britain had fallen to Nazi
Germany's tanks and planes Hitler's
relentless aggression had transformed
the continent of Europe into one huge
prison house in my talks this week I'll
explain the pivotal programs and the
crucial strategic plans that Roosevelt
initiated and supported during his third
hundred days today I'll speak about
three things first the nation's shift
and Roosevelt's shift away from
isolationism second plan dog is anybody
ever heard a plan dog I don't know
anyone who has you have planned dog is
the strategic plan that outlined
American priorities and goals if the
United States entered the war and third
the American British conversations the
ABC talks that gave the two countries a
forum to coordinate strategy tomorrow
I'll speak about the lend-lease act that
provided planes ships and tanks to Great
Britain free of charge and free of
strings and the Prime Minister Winston
Churchill called the most unsorted act
in the whole of recorded history and on
Thursday I'll discuss the roles that
labor management and government played
in putting the nation's entire economy
an industrial production on a wartime
basis in November 1940 Roosevelt was not
yet fully engaged in the urgency of the
world crisis there was no disguising his
ambivalence about American involvement
in the war he understood that the US
needed more time to rearm and he was
reluctant to move too far ahead of
public opinion during the first few
weeks after his election victory his
indecision created the sense of a
government adrift he was weary after the
campaign and he spent much of the
post-election weeks reading cruising
fishing discussing and reflecting but by
mid-december he had all but abandoned
that ambivalence the decisions and plans
that were made during Roosevelt's third
hundred days constituted a forward move
away from the isolationism that had
shaped American foreign policy since the
end of World War one and it signaled a
new awareness that the United States had
to play a defining political military
and moral role in international affairs
and in fact it was two of your fellow
yeh Lee's who urged Americans to embrace
that international awareness in February
1941 while congress was considering the
lend-lease act a 1920 Yale graduate
named Henry Luce think we're in loose
hole right now 1920 Yale graduate named
Henry Luce published an article in life
magazine entitled the American Century
loose had been the managing editor of
the Yale Daily News and was now the
influential publisher of lifetime and
fortune in his article the media mogul
scolded Americans for failing and I
quote to play their part as a world
power a failure that has had disastrous
consequences for themselves and for all
mankind Luce cold on his own Republican
Party to cleanse itself of what he
labeled the virus of isolationist
sterility and he called on his fellow
citizens to recognize and act on their
moral obligation to other nations he
wrote that it was time for America to
Rican sieve its global role and destiny
another Yale graduate Henry Stimson
class of 1889 was also a strong
internationalist he was a lifelong
Republican who had served as president
William Howard Taft Secretary of War and
Herbert Hoover Secretary of State before
becoming FDR Secretary of War
stimson adamantly rejected the ostrich
like isolationism that had swept over
the country and like loose he urged the
United States to accept it's vital
obligation to always think and act with
a sense of planetary responsibility he
wrote that every policy in America
whether private or public must be framed
with reference to the world otherwise he
said it is framed with perfect futility
but before yeh Lee's get too excited
about their wonderful alums let me
remind them that the most powerful and
influential isolationist movement began
at Yale in the spring of nineteen forty
Yale students Douglas Stuart the son of
a vice president of Quaker Oats Gerald
Ford the future president Potter Stewart
the future Supreme Court justice a
senior named Kingman Brewster and others
drafted a petition that stated we demand
that Congress refrained from war even if
England is on the verge of defeat
they're naive solution to the crisis lay
in a negotiated peace with Hitler
eventually wealthy Chicago
industrialists funded the movement and
turned it into the America first
committee the AFC's charismatic
spokesman would be the heroic aviator
Charles Lindbergh from nineteen thirty
nine to nineteen forty one a ferocious
debate raged in the United States about
American foreign policy it was a bitter
divisive clash between isolationists and
interventionists that tore apart
families and friends churches
universities and political parties let
me sketch out for you who these
isolationists were many were probably
well-meaning although I'm not sure they
were deeply scarred by the memories of
the pointless mass slaughter trench
warfare and poisoned mustard gas of the
First World War
determination to retreat from foreign
affairs had been emboldened by the 1934
Senate committee hearings chaired by
Republican Gerald Nye of North Dakota
that sought to investigate whether
bankers and profit seeking munitions
makers had played a role in propelling
the nation into that first world war
most isolationists agreed with Charles
Lindbergh that the United States was
protected by two vast oceans and was
therefore invulnerable to any attack
they rejected the idea that the security
of the United States hinged on the fate
of Great Britain and they were willing
to come to terms with Hitler and many of
them had been persuaded by lindbergh
that the Germans had made such great
advances in aviation technology the
Germany was invincible and still other
isolationists maintained the democracy
in the United States was fragile and
couldn't survive another war and still
others were anti-semitic and sheared
Lindbergh when he declared at an America
first rally and I quote the leaders of
the British and Jewish races for which
for reasons which are not American
wished to involve us in the war and when
he warned against Jewish ownership and
influence and what he referred to as our
motion pictures our press our radio and
our government and some isolationists
drank the kool-aid and embraced the idea
of an Aryan master race here's Lindbergh
on the radio in 1939 our bond with
Europe is a bond of race and not of
political ideology racial strength is
vital politics a luxury you Jen assists
like Lindbergh's mentor Alexis Carrel
deployed their pseudo scientific
theories to support the idea that
Germany was protecting Europe against
racially inferior Slavs Asians
and of course Jews and some
isolationists were simply pro-fascist
for example Lindbergh's wife and morrow
lindbergh at the height of the 1940
election season she published an elegant
lyrical book called the wave of the
future the jumped to the top of the
bestseller list from the outside it
looked like a lovely apple but it was
rotten to the core building on the
pro-fascist writings of Lawrence Dennis
a Harvard graduate who was known as the
brains of American fascism and Lindbergh
argued that the conflict taking place in
Europe between democratic and fascist
nations was not between good and evil
but rather between the forces of the
past and those of the future democracy
Oh was so clearly and sadly inefficient
exhausted and outmoded the future
belonged to the dynamism and energy of a
dazzling fascist World Order and there's
no point in resisting the wave of the
future and some isolationists were
Christian pacifists the theologian
Reinhold Niebuhr struggled to awaken
them to the futility of pacifism he
asked how could a true Christian
conscience not recoil from Hitler's
tyrannical goal of destroying the
precious heritage of Christian
humanistic culture as for those
Christians who didn't understand the
urgency and necessity of the just war
against Hitler niebuhr recommended that
they retire to a monastery where he said
medieval perfectionists found their
asylum and finally of course some
isolationist simply hated Roosevelt for
them the aim was to defeat not Hitler
but FDR and using isolationism as their
sledgehammer all these currents made up
the potent and virulent opposition to
any policy that would lead the United
States nearer to intervention in the war
and row
the veldt as the leader of a democratic
republic was indeed constrained by
public opinion and had no choice but to
be sensitive to the will of the majority
otherwise democracy would disintegrate
the European dictators used compulsion
but FDR had to rely on education and the
art of persuasion now let's return to
the wonderful Yale alum Henry Stimson in
june nineteen forty he spoke during the
yale commencement weekend about the
grave crisis facing the United States
the greatest crisis in the nation's
history he told students and alumni and
I quote the international emergency
strikes at the very existence of all
that our country has cherished and
fought for since its founding and then
he offered three concrete proposals
repeal of the misguided neutrality act
the sending of planes and other
munitions immediately to Britain and
closest to his heart universal
compulsory military service after his
talk all those at the meeting including
Yale President Charles Seymour voted
unanimously for a resolution advocating
a military draft in 1915 before the u.s.
entered World War 1 he was among the
first to enroll in something called the
businessmen's military training camp in
Plattsburgh New York it was a volunteer
movement of college graduates who
believed in military preparedness when
the u.s. entered the war in 1917
Stimpson was already 50 years old but he
volunteered to serve in the army and
reached the rank of colonel during the
1930s the decade of open German Italian
and Japanese aggression he gave talks
and wrote articles condemning
isolationism a few days after Stimson
speech at yale in june nineteen forty
President Roosevelt phoned him and asked
him to be his new Secretary of War the
72 year old Stimpson had one question
for the president
did he know about the talk he had just
given at Yale yes FDR said he indeed had
read the text of the speech and he
agreed with it Stimpson was particularly
pleased that his talk here in New Haven
had put him on the record as a staunch
interventionist there was no doubt about
Stimson's contempt for isolationism at
his Senate confirmation hearings he told
the members of the Military Affairs
Committee that at a time of
unprecedented peril he couldn't
understand as he put it the hopelessly
twisted views of a small group of men
who in the name of peace want to keep
America from acting against the greatest
aggression in history he scorned the
notion that the nation could rely on
purely passive defense and he ridiculed
the idea of waiting for the enemy to
attack our shores in fact Stimson's
interventionist views were far stronger
than Roosevelt's the president had
brought into his inner circle a man who
would try to push him toward a path he
was reluctant to take in Stimson's
amazingly detailed an informative diary
which is available online he described
his frustration with his elusive
commander-in-chief in December 1940 he
wrote that the president I quote hops
around in his discussions from
suggestion to suggestion and it's very
much like chasing a vagrant beam of
sunshine around a vacant room that
portrait of Roosevelt was quite accurate
for years the President had equivocated
and fluctuated in response to fascist
aggression in the fall of nineteen
thirty-seven after the japanese launched
a brutal incursion into China Roosevelt
gave a speech in Chicago saying that the
United States could no longer hide from
international lawlessness through
isolation or neutrality he called for
McCracken's to quarantine the aggressors
but what exactly did quarantine mean he
proposed no plan no economic sanctions
or any other type of coercion on the
contrary he made it clear that the US
would not go beyond expressing moral
indignation in September 1939 when
German troops took over Poland Roosevelt
stayed on the sidelines in a fireside
chat a few days later he assured
Americans that the United States would
remain a neutral nation he admitted that
he didn't expect Americans to close
their minds or their consciences to Nazi
brutality but he also confessed his deep
antipathy to war I hate war he said as
long as it remains within my power to
prevent it there will be no blackout of
peace in the United States but in the
late spring of nineteen forty the
situation changed dramatically the Nazis
swift march of victory through Western
Europe had left Great Britain standing
alone as the last European Bastion
against Germany Roosevelt requested
billions of dollars from Congress for
the expansion of the Army in the Navy
and that fall he signed the selective
service act authorizing the first
peacetime draft in American history in
addition in a clear break from
neutrality he gave Britain 50 World War
1 destroyers in exchange for a 99 year
lease for British naval and air bases in
Newfoundland Bermuda and the Caribbean
that famous destroyers four bases deal
was actually an idea first proposed by
Henry Luce when he dined with Roosevelt
that past July at the White House of
course events created new pressures in
September 1940 Germany Italy and Japan
signed the tribe part tripartite pact
and two weeks later FDR
gave a strongly-worded columbus day talk
he declared that no combination of
dictator countries in Europe and Asia
will hold us in the path we see ahead
for ourselves and for democracy but
there were counter pressures to above
all Roosevelt's campaign for re-election
at a time when the voting public was
anxious about the prospect of war in
campaign speeches that October the third
term candidate bowed down before a new
God the God of no far and war it must
have been bewildering for the crowd in
Madison Square Garden to hear the
president praised the Neutrality Act
that he had bitterly criticised and
opposed in 1935 and 1936 and in Boston a
week before the election American
mothers and fathers listened intently as
he made an emotional pledge I shall say
it again and again and again your boys
are not going to be sent into any
foreign wars the back of his mind
Roosevelt reasoned that if the United
States was attacked and would no longer
be a far in war and rather than risk
losing the election he made promises
that were unrealistic at best in his
struggle to stake out a politically safe
middle ground between war and isolation
Roosevelt frequently emphasized the
Monroe Doctrine of 18 23 and the
importance of defense of the Western
Hemisphere this was an uncontroversial
stance that was unlikely to infuriate
internationalists or to alienate
isolationists for they all considered
the Americas as their domain I think it
was impossible to find in all this a
coherent u.s. position on the world
conflict Roosevelt was offering
confusing messages of military
preparedness to increase defense
spending and production defiance of the
Axis powers assurances of neutrality
promises of no war and hemispheric 25
sense but there was one unstated
constant Roosevelt's bottom line
whatever the peril he was not going to
lead the country into war he was going
to wait to be pushed in but Henry
Stimson didn't want to wait until the
country was pushed into war he wanted
the president to lead and not merely
follow public opinion and Stimson wasn't
alone he was a member of a brilliant
quartet that included army chief of
staff George Marshall FDR's new
secretary of the Navy Frank Knox and
Admiral Harold Stark the naval chief of
operations amid mounting signs that the
United States might soon be at war the
four decided to act and steer the
hesitant president toward intervention
they understood that the Army Navy and
Air Force needed an overarching grand
strategic plan to meet future
contingencies they agreed that it was
absolutely essential to determine what
the nation's core priorities were
whether to take the offensive in the
Atlantic or in the Pacific whether to
defeat Germany first or Japan the early
fall of nineteen forty general Marshall
briefly and succinctly outlined the
essence of what would become the
overriding goal of American strategy one
our national interest is the survival of
the British Empire and the defeat of
Germany too we must avoid dispersions
that might lessen our power to operate
effectively in the principal theater the
Atlantic in other words as Marshall
straightforwardly wrote if we lose in
the Atlantic we lose everywhere Marshall
believed that the United States was
already overextended in the Pacific he
told Admiral Stark and i quote a serious
commitment in the Pacific is just what
Germany would like to see us undertake
stark nim saat stims
knocks all agreed with Marshall on an
Atlantic first strategy stark warned
that if Britain fell to the Nazis we
would find ourselves acting alone and at
war with the world but America's
priorities and goals needed to be
codified or formalized so that the Army
Navy and Army and Navy Chiefs had a
well-defined blueprint for how to
achieve the paramount goal as well as a
solid basis for coordinating their
planning and so in the late fall of
nineteen forty Admiral Stark decided to
compose an analysis of the situation for
his colleagues and for the president in
the quiet of his home he worked for 18
straight hours on a draft of just such a
blueprint with military concision he
methodically assessed the international
situation laid out several scenarios
based on different objectives and
articulated what he and the other
members of the quartet believed was
America's prime objective finally he
weighed the country's capabilities in
light of that objective taking into
account not only the level of the
military's readiness but also what he
called the political realities in our
own country his aim he unpretentiously
told Frank Knox was merely to shed some
light upon the major decisions that the
President may make for guiding our
future military and naval efforts in the
event of a war and in further immediate
preparations for war it was a very
humble goal for a document that outlined
the course that the United States would
follow for the next five years through
the utterly unforeseen events of the
most destructive war in human history
stark wrote his report himself on an
ancient device technically technically
known as a manual typewriter it was
double spaced and 26 pages long
written and non-aggressive everyday
language on the first page he explained
that his intention was to present his
views concerning steps we might take to
meet the situation that will exist if
the United States enters the war either
alone or with allies and then he posed
the crucial question where should we
fight the war and for what objective and
he offered four different scenarios plan
a proposed that the United States
maintain a purely defensive posture in
the Western Hemisphere and avoid any
involvement in the war for as long as
possible neither in the East nor the
West would we do anything more than
provide material help to America's
allies it was a plan that would do
nothing extraordinary to head to a
Briton even though the quartet believed
that the survival of Britain was
essential to European security Stark's
plan be laid out a strictly defensive
posture in the Atlantic but a full
offensive against Japan in the Pacific
he explained that this option placed
full confidence in the British to hold
their own indefinitely in the Atlantic
while the US would focus on defeating
Japan but he also proposed that if Great
Britain was losing in its struggle
against Nazi Germany the US would have
to immediately reorient toward the
Atlantic here comes Plan C this was the
nightmare scenario it envisaged a
two-front war with the u.s. sending the
strongest possible military assistance
to Britain as well as to the Far East
the handicap of fighting two major wars
in two theatres at the same time was of
course mind boggling stark acknowledged
that such a two-front war would disperse
US forces and virtually preclude
successful operations in either theater
the last scenario was planned d
it had the United States directing its
efforts toward a strong offensive in the
Atlantic as an ally of Britain while
maintaining only a defensive position
against Japan in the Pacific plan D
stipulated that if the United States was
forced into a war with Japan it would
still avoid major operations in the
Pacific until the Atlantic front and
Britain were entirely secure of course
circumstances would ultimately determine
American actions but taking all probable
factors into account stark firmly
recommended that the Roosevelt
administration adopt plan D he rejected
the other options as counterproductive
and he gave four reasons why first the
secure existence of Britain and its
Empire would do the most to ensure the
security of the United States and the
Western Hemisphere second it was Germany
and not Japan that most seriously
threatened Britain security and even its
survival third therefore it was Germany
that also posed the greatest danger to
the security of the United States and
finally for stark wrote that in the
interest of American and British
security America's full offensive
strength must be exerted in one single
direction and Atlantic first and a
defeat Germany strategy the adoption of
planned dog or plan sorry a plan D or
planned dog as it was called a naval
parlance would mean that the fate of the
United States would be inextricably
bound to that of Britain that we would
do everything we could to meet Britain's
vital needs and that American soldiers
might have to fight in a land war in
Europe while Roosevelt was promising
that your boys are not going to be sent
into any foreign wars Admiral Stark was
already envisioning American
participation in a full-scale land
offensive in Europe of course stark
knew that the United States was still
building up its own military strength
and wasn't yet ready to engage in
offensive actions and so he advised that
for the very near future Roosevelt adopt
plan a hemispheric defense with only
material aid to the Allies Roosevelt's
response to the planned dog memorandum
with something of a mystery he never
signaled outright approval but he also
gave no sign of disapproval and so
Marshall Stimson Knox and stark adopted
the Atlantic first strategy because the
president didn't say they couldn't FDR's
tacit acquiescence left the quartet free
to conclude that military strategy would
be left to the leaders of the military
the credit goes to Admiral Stark it was
he who seized the initiative and fought
to bring order and coherence to what had
been a muddle and above all it was he
who drafted a plan that was true to both
the shape of the world crisis and to the
potential leadership role of the United
States even though in 1942 and most of
43 more American forces were in fact
deployed against Japan than against
Germany plan dog nevertheless defined
America's paramount wartime strategy and
goals in fact it was the fundamental US
strategic decision of the war now with
the goal of defending Britain and
defeating germany how would the
Americans and the British coordinate
their planning and their actions the
last crucial recommendation in Starks
memo was that members of the American
military senior staff hold secret talks
that winter in Washington with their
British counterparts as a preliminary
two possible American entry into the war
general Marshall completely agreed with
the necessity of such meetings
after the war he wrote if we hadn't had
some talks with the British we would
have started with no basis at all if we
entered the war we needed to have at
least a vague idea of what we could
expect from the British and what sort of
help they would want from us another
reason for proposing join talks was that
both Marshall and Stark had serious
misgivings about the competence of
British military leaders in fact they
feared that the American military effort
would be sabotaged by British ineptitude
and miscalculation ironically Prime
Minister Churchill had no objections to
the low opinion that American America's
top military of officers held of the
fitness of the British for battle the
Prime Minister reasoned that the more
floundering the Britain appeared the
more likely it was that the United
States would rush to her aid Churchill
wrote that it was particularly helpful
that American military leaders
considered Britain incapable of winning
alone Roosevelt approved the talks but
demanded that they be kept absolutely
secret one of his advisers commented
that if the Germans and Japanese had
learned of the talks no great damage
would have been done because they would
have expected as much but had the
isolationists in Congress found out then
American preparations for war might have
been wrecked Roosevelt began a mid
January meeting at the White House with
marshal Stimson knox and stark by
soberly laying out the very grave
situation he said that there was one
chance in five the Germany would invade
Britain immediately in which case
Britain might survive for six months at
best he emphasized the importance of
keeping the British supplied with all
they needed even in the event of an axis
attack on the unite
States the US he said would simply have
to be ready to act with what we have
available then he outlined the position
he wanted the Americans to take at the
joint talks in other words these were
their marching orders one we would stand
on the defensive in the Pacific with the
fleet based on Hawaii to the Navy should
be prepared to convoy shipping in the
Atlantic to England three the army
should not engage in offensive action
until it was fully prepared for our
military course must be conservative
until our strength is fully developed
five we will make every effort to supply
war materiel to Great Britain this was
Admiral Starks memorandum in a nutshell
Roosevelt didn't mention plan dog by
name but his directions could be
interpreted as a comprehensive
endorsement on January 24th 1941 the
Royal Navy ship King George the fifth
arrived in Chesapeake Bay newspapers
reported that on board was the new
British ambassador to the US Lord
Halifax but they didn't report that also
arriving were representatives of the
British Chiefs of Staff they were
camouflaged in civilian clothes and
their assignment was to participate in
high-level confidential discussions with
their American counterparts to create a
joint strategy for war five days later
the American British conversations or
ABC got underway and would continue for
two months until the end of March the
Americans opened the conversations with
a statement of the u.s. position at the
present time the United States would
remain out of the war but it would
provide all material and economic aid to
Great Britain but if the United States
was compelled to resort to war it was
committed to the defeat of Germany and
Atlantic first strategy the US was also
committed to the containment of Japan
but even if it had to conduct military
operations against Japan it would limit
those operations so as not to diminish
America's main effort in the Atlantic it
was once again plan dog in a nutshell
the British accepted nearly all of the
American state of the American statement
and goals especially the number one
priority of defeating germany but they
clashed over Britain's determination to
maintain control over its global empire
and protect its interests in the Far
East from India and Burma to Australia
and New Zealand the British
representatives at the abc talks
believed that the defense of those
interests hinged entirely on their naval
base in Singapore and that the loss of
Singapore would be a disaster the bottom
line was that the British wanted the
Americans to send a fleet to Singapore
but the Americans didn't want to do the
dirty work of salvaging the British
Empire and so the subject of Singapore
provoked a bitter stalemate in the talks
when Prime Minister Churchill heard
about his staff's intransigent position
on Singapore he blew his stack what has
been the use I wish I could say this
with his accident I can't what has been
the use of all this battling he said our
sole object is to get the Americans into
the war if they prefer Hawaii to
Singapore there is no more to be said
despite this conflict in other clashes
the talks brought substantial agreements
Britain was assured of American help in
the Atlantic and there was no argument
about the importance of defeating Nazi
Germany first the Brits accepted that
the American presence in the Pacific
would remain a defensive one with its
main fleet stationed in Hawaii as a
deterrent to Japanese aggression the ABC
talks were
clear win for the United States but
above all planned dog had become and
would remain the operative strategy for
the United States and for Britain one
senior British staff member called it
the Bible of our joint collaboration and
not even Pearl Harbor would change that
we know the disputes between Britain and
the United States over strategic policy
would continue the two countries would
calculate and plot their decisions
according to their own national and
imperial interests and once Americans
were in the war Churchill would not
always be as yielding as he was during
the ABC talks but the talks had created
a partnership that could withstand the
bitterest of disagreements to come and
that would soon evolve into permanent
joint military and naval missions in
London and Washington with staffs
numbering in the hundreds for his part
Winston Churchill was elated about the
new era that was dawning after the war
he wrote we were conscious of the
tremendous changes taking place in
American opinion and of the growing
belief not only in Washington but
throughout the country that their fate
was bound up with ours and in March 1941
nine months before Pearl Harbor the new
Anglo American alliance was
indestructible anchored on both sides of
the Atlantic I'll conclude by saying
that although the United States remained
at the moment in a gray area neither a
pea snort war plan dog and the ABC talks
demonstrate that in late nineteen forty
in early 41 despite all his caution
Roosevelt grasp the likely course of
events and thanks to prodding by
Marshall Stimson knox and stark he
approved crucial preparations for war
during his third hundred days he made no
public declaration of his intentions
his thoughts about the inevitability of
American involvement in the global
conflict but plans for war we're now
unmistakeably and irrevocably underway
thank you